foreign
Justin is up next in Denver hey Justin
welcome to the show
hi Rachel hi John uh read both of your
books loved them oh thanks so much well
thanks for calling yep how can we help
my wife and I my wife and I are in baby
step two we paid off forty thousand
dollars in the last five months wow
congratulations thank you we're
celebrating our four year anniversary
next week and
um just this morning my wife told me
that her father
uh had uh told us that he was forgiving
uh the seven thousand dollars balance of
a ten thousand dollar family loan
um that they loaned us prior to our
marriage
um that's generous and uh yeah they live
close by and they come over often and I
fear that in the future once they
forgive this debt if I
um continue on they will uh I I just
fear facing them
do you fear facing them like ego wise or
is this loan forgiveness come with
strings federal government I like
no my my wife says and swears up and
down that they are not like that and I
believe her okay
um and she's she's on board with me she
hates owing anybody any money this is
our last debt before we move on to uh
baby step three and
um and I I I just can't bring myself to
feel right about the Forgiveness why not
well the original family loan was for
her to pay for her lawyer fees
um her ex-husband and her daughter
um per the divorce agreement or whatever
we're supposed to stay in the same
county as her husband
um for a visitation or whatever and she
wanted to move in with me prior to us
getting married and
um that created
um a Family Law Court case
um which she needed a lawyer for so from
my perspective I saw her parents as
taking a bet on me when her biological
father would not do that they bet on our
relationship uh it's been a very Rocky
marriage just because of the ends of the
spectrum that both of us fall while
she's a mental health counselor I'm
retired army
so they're betting on our marriage from
my point of view and it just pains me to
have this debt forgiven
um Let me let me reframe this let me
reframe this I don't think anybody's
betting on anybody sounds like a mom and
dad who love their daughter
and it sounds like a mom and dad who
love their daughter and trust you
there's nobody's gambling on anything
here
and so
in your marriage by the way isn't been
Rocky because you're in the Army and
she's a mental health counselor it's
because it's just been Rocky make some
different choices
you know what I mean like don't don't
over dramatize this it sounds a lot like
you don't like the ego of this it's I
mean this is about your ego
that's what it sounds like
and if I'm you I would walk over to his
house or drive over there and I'd knock
on his door and I'd stick my hand out
and shake his hand if not hug him and
say thank you
and then when you are on more secure
Financial footing and you feel compelled
to pay the seven thousand bucks back and
you're in a position to do so then go do
it at that point and let some space
happen between there or if suddenly he's
holding this over your head and
weaponizing it then go take out a loan
at a credit union and give him his money
back
but I this sounds a lot like ego man and
this isn't the moment for ego this is a
moment to say thank you I'm grateful
but you've created a conflict like
they're betting on this and I I'm dude
just say thank you man
and then be about making your marriage
Stronger Yeah and Justin do you is there
patterns with your relationship with
them that's causing you to to get here
because at this point I feel like you
said that it's been a pretty good
relationship with them and you haven't
seen anything but have you deep down is
there something that you're like oh God
they've made that comment that comment
that comment that's helped you write the
story or is it just it just feels so I
mean you just kind of can't believe oh
my gosh that this debt he's gonna just
forgive it and then you kind of start
rattling around in your in your head
with it
uh I'm not really sure what's going on
with that I I know that you know over
the last nine ten months now I've I've
had a lot of shame in my life
um
uh you know I've I quit drinking 10
months ago and uh
um so there's a lot of shame
I destroyed some relationships and uh
you know the worst one was uh trust with
my wife and I'm trying to rebuild those
relationships and my life's it seems
like my life is cool isn't that on me
I'm getting the help that I need
excellent um
let me tell you something that's
counterintuitive to the space you're in
the space you're in especially with your
training is that you are going to grab
control
I'm going to quote unquote solve this I
screwed something up fix it right that's
the mentality and that there is some
truth to that you've got to do right by
your wife you've got to repair that
relationship and that comes with doing
different things
but globally speaking grabbing the wheel
tighter
is not going to stop the spin of this
thing
it's releasing that
and what that looks like is going to
somebody's house and saying thank you
the word that nobody likes to use is
vulnerability and that's the only path
forward for you and vulnerability for
for a veteran is counterintuitive I'm
rolling you could hurt me right now
and I'm gonna go anyway
because you're my wife because you're my
in-laws you're my family now
and I'm going to trust that you won't
hurt me and I'm going to say thank you
I'm gonna go on to being a good man is
that fair
yes I want you to very much but listen
brother I want you to look at this not
as like I told the previous caller this
isn't a some kind of moral failure
this is a set of skills you don't have
and you gotta learn some new skills and
you got to practice them is that cool
yes so practice accepting help practice
think thank you and then and then
practice saying I'm sorry how can we
make this right
okay is that cool
yes go make your marriage good man
you're worth that it's good Justin
appreciate you man and that's a lot of
Courage it's a bold calling yeah yeah
it's a brave guy I really appreciate you
calling Justin but and it's a there's a
level in all of this right in our lives
whether it's within our marriage within
our money
uh anything new even accepting a gift
right
um all of it to your point I'm like when
you don't have the practice and the
skills it's it is so uncomfortable and
it is so scary But continuing to step
into it and continuing to take a step it
takes courage a different level of
Courage than I feel like our world talks
about well there's it's it's relational
courage which is like like if if Suzanne
fires me she takes my job from me right
but my identities with my wife and kids
whatever
if I lose that then I've got it that's
that's a long road right I don't know
who I am I'm untethered to everything
right and so there's something
incredibly Courageous about leaning into
someone that you love and care about who
is part of you which is your wife your
husband your spouse your kids and saying
I'm sorry
thank you how do I do this right like we
just don't have we don't have a culture
that just says I'm sorry how do I make
this right we have one that says fix it
and when we fix it we try to grab
control of it yes and sometimes you
gotta do the opposite of what you're
what your training is yeah which is so
scary and that's the vulnerable piece
when you're not used to that and it's
like okay I really am I'm gonna I'm
gonna let go of the wheel in a sense
um and other other people who have spent
their whole lives with their hands off
the wheel equally as courageous you've
got to grab the wheel like you've got to
take some control here right and and so
some people are listening going like
okay I should look like you got to know
you and everybody's situation is
different it's it's doing the if you
here's the thing look at the pattern of
behavior in your life
look back and say is this working this
is your four and my marriage is still a
mess me getting angry every time this or
me going to watch Netflix every time or
grabbing another drink every time that's
not working let's try something else do
the courageous thing that makes your
body uncomfortable because that usually
is the right thing yeah trying something
the next hard thing that's so good well
thanks again Justin for calling it's
awesome